>>> EARLIER IN THE BROADCAST WE
WERE DCUSSING GINNI THOMAS,
THE WIFE OF CLARENCE THOMAS.
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE CHAIR
SAYS THEY NOW WANT HER TO APPEAR
BEFORE THE PANEL.
SHE TOLD A CONSERVATIVE
PUBLICATION THAT SHE'S OPEN TO
THE IDEA AND, QUOTE, CAN'T WAIT
TO CLEAR UP MISCONCEPTIONS.
THOMAS IS OF INTEREST IN LARGE
PART AS HER CORRESPONDENCE AS
ONE OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
TOP ADVISERS.
RANDI KAYE HAS MORE.
>> CLARENCE THOMAS, YOU'RE THE
BEST MAN WALKING THE FACE OF THE
EARTH.
>> Reporter: GINNI THOMAS HAS
SOME EXPLAINING TO DO, LIKE,
WHAT ABOUT THOSE EMAILS SHE
EXCHANGED WITH CONSERVATIVE
ATTORNEY JOHN EASTMAN, WHO THE
HOUSE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE SAYS
HELPED DEVISE A SCHEME.
IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT GINNI THOMAS
SAID TO EASTMAN IN THE EMAILS OR
IF SHE WILL APPEAR BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TO TRY TO EXPLAIN ANY
OF IT.
THE COMMITTEE IS ALSO
INVESTIGATING MORE THAN TWO
DOZEN TEXT MESSAGES GINNI THOMAS
SENT JUST DAYS AFTER BIDEN'S
VICTORY TO MARK MEADOWS, WHO WAS
DONALD TRUMP'S CHIEF OF STAFF.
>> THE SECOND REAGAN REVOLUTION
IS GROWING.
>> IN ONE TEXT FROM NOVEMBER OF
2020, GINNI THOMAS WROTE TO
MEADOWS, HELP THIS GREAT
PRESIDENT STAND FIRM, MARK.
THE MAJORITY KNOWS BIDEN AND THE
LEFT IS ATTEMPTING THE GREATEST
HEIST OF OUR HISTORY.
IN ANOTHER, SHE SEEMED TO
EMBRACE A LONG-HELD FALSE QANON
CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT TRUMP HAD
WATER MARKED MAIL-IN BALLOTS SO
HE COULD TRACK POTENTIAL FRAUD.
SHE WROTE TO MEADOWS, WATER
MARKED BALLOTS IN OVER 12 STATE
VERSUS BEEN PART OF A HUGE TRUMP
AND MILITARY WHITE HAT STING
OPERATION IN KEY BATTLEGROUND
STATES.
AND GINNI THOMAS ALSO STOOD BY
LAWYER SIDNEY POWELL WHO STOOD
THE CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT
ELECTRONIC VOTING MACHINES HAD
SOMEHOW SWITCHES BALLOTS FROM
TRUMP TO BIDEN.
SHE WROTE TO MEADOWS, SOUNDS
LIKE SIDNEY AND HER TEAM ARE
GETTING INUNDATED WITH EVIDENCE
OF FRAUD.
MAKE A PLAN, RELEASE THE KRAKEN,
SAVE US FROM THE LEFT, TAKING
AMERICA DOWN.
AT ONE POINT, "THE WASHINGTON
POST" REPORTS GINNI THOMAS URGED
HER HUSBAND TO WATCH A VIDEO
ABOUT THE POWER ABOUT NOT
CONCEDING.
GINNI THOMAS SAID SHE BRIEFLY
ATTENDED THE JANUARY 6th RALLY
AT THE CAPITOL BUT RETURNED HOME
BEFORE THE INSURRECTION.
GINNI THOMAS DID NOT RESPOND TO
CNN'S REQUEST FOR COMMENT, AND
EASTMAN'S ATTORNEY DECLINED TO
COMMENT.
>> MY WIFE IS TOTALLY MY BEST
FRIEND.
>> Reporter: ACCORDING TO
CLARENCE THOMAS' 2004 BEST
FRIEND, GINNI THOMAS WAS BORN
VIRGINIA LAMP.
HER MOTHER WAS AN OUTSPOKEN
REPUBLICAN ACTIVIST WHO PLAYED A
PROMINENT ROLE IN HER DAUGHTER'S
LIFE.
ACCORDING TO "THE NEW YORK
TIMES," SHE JOINED HER HIGH
SCHOOL'S REPUBLICAN CLUB IN
1974.
LATER, AT CREIGHTON UNIVERSITY
IN OMAHA, SHE EARNED A LAW
DEGREE AND MOVED TO WASHINGTON
TO WORK AS AN AIDE FOR HAL DOG,
A CONSERVATIVE FROM NEBRASKA.
SHE REPORTEDLY MET CLARENCE
THOMAS AT A CONFERENCE ON
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
THEY MARRIED IN 1987.
>> I KEPT A SIGN ON MY DESK.
DON'T MAKE FUN OF YOUR WIFE'S
CHOICES.
YOU WERE ONE OF THEM.
>> Reporter: IN 1991 IN THE
"WASHINGTON POST," A FRIEND
DESCRIBED THE COUP